لا يوجد ربط علمي بين حدوث الزلازل
والتغير المناخي ولكن الاخير لا يقل خطوره
عن الزلزال لان المدن الكبرى في العالم
اجمع مهدده بالغرق ومستقبل البشريه ايضا
بسبب ارتفاع مستوى البحار وفق ما كشفته
الامم المتحده فالخطر سيكون كبير لان 900
مليون شخص ممن يعيشون في المناطق الساحليه
حياتهم مهدده بالكامل بعدما ارتفعت درجه
حراره المحيطات العالميه خلال القرن
الماضي بشكل اسرع من اي وقت مضى وافقت
تقرير الاممي المنظمه العالميه للارصاد
الجويه تقول لان درجه الحراره العالميه
بلغت واحد فاصله خمسه درجه مئويه مما
يساهم بارتفاع كبير في مستوى سطح البحار
وايضا التقرير حذر من ان درجات الحراره
مرشحه للارتفاع بمقدار درجتين وهذا الامر
سيؤدي الى ارتفاع هائل بمستوى البحار
ويهدد بقاء المناطق الساحليه في العالم
مياه البحار مالحه
ستدمر وستدمر وتتلف البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه في كل المناطق التي ستضربها
المياه كما نشاهد بهذه الصور وستتسبب
بتدمير الوظائف والاقتصادات باكملها في
صناعات رئيسيه مثل الزراعه ومصائد الاسماك
والسياحه المدن الكبرى مشاهدينا في كل
قارات ستواجه تداعيات خطيره بما في ذلك
لاجوس واشنجهاي ولندن ولاس انجلوس
ونيويورك وغيرها من الدول والمناطق في
جميع انحاء العالم يؤدي ارتفاع درجات
حراره الكوكب الى ذوبان الانهار والصفائح
الجليديه حيث تفقد القاره القطبيه
الجنوبيه ما معدلهم 150
من كتله الجليد سنويا والغطاء الجليدي في
يذوب ايضا بشكل في جرينلان تحديدا يذوب
بشكل اسرع مما يؤدي الى فقدان 270 مليار
طن سنويا وفق ارقام الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]